Good morning John.
Today I’m going to teach you how
to do one of the most important
things you can do to help
mitigate climate change.
It’s something anyone can do,
and if you watch this video you
will be better at it than almost
everyone on Earth.
But first,
a little background.
Every 6 or
7 years, the UN puts out a report
about climate change: where we
are, what it looks like, how we’re
doing, and one of those came out
this week.
And the result was a
whole lot of headlines that do
not look good.
And yeah,
things aren’t good.
But also I was really glad to
have come across this tweet:
“As a climate scientist,
I’d like you to know: I don’t
have hope.
I have something better:
certainty.
We know exactly
what’s causing climate change.
We can absolutely avoid the worst
and build a better world in the process.
And that is certainly nice.
We know what is causing
this problem.
We know how to solve it.
And indeed, in a way we are.
Like renewable energy is skyrocketing
and yeah solar is producing just 1% of
the world’s energy right now
but it’s increasing faster every year.
Per capita CO2 emissions in the US
are lower than they were in 1918.
Now that was some very cherry-picked data.
Things are not good.
We are running
an experiment on our life support
system and we know that the result
is going to be bad we just don’t
know how bad.
The IPCC report is clear,
we are not headed in a good direction.
To avoid the worst consequences
we are going to have to keep global
increase in temperature below 2 degrees
Celsius or a little less than 4 degrees Fahrenheit.
Currently we are not on target to
do that even if we keep to all the
agreements we have.
We need to
quickly stop putting greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere and
also quickly start taking them
back out.
Now the two most common
questions I am asked about climate change
are 1.) is there actually any hope here?
And 2.)
what should I do?
Now as for the first question, yes.
Well it depends on what you mean,
is there hope that we will experience
no negative impacts from climate change?
No.
No there’s not.
We’re already
experiencing them.
So climate change
is going to make life worse.
But we don’t
know how much worse, and if you’re
watching this video the chances
are it’s going to be much worse for
other people than it is for you.
Global warming, like almost every
issue, is a justice issue.
It will have
the biggest impacts on the people
who are least responsible for it.
People who are relatively affluent
and live in relatively affluent
places will be mostly, though not all, ok.
Like not great, but okay.
But the less you have, the harder
it is to deal with the destabilizations
that come from a changing climate.
And as for the second, like a lot.
You
should be doing a lot.
But you also
have other stuff to do, like you
have to take care of your friends
and family, you have to go school,
you gotta pay your loans, you gotta
do your work, you gotta goof off
sometimes.
But in between all of that,
yes, climate change is the most
important and difficult issue humanity faces.
And so, there are things you can do
both to show the world this is a crisis,
and to mitigate your impact.
Eat less or no meat, especially
not beef, never buy a gas powered
car ever again if you can avoid it,
especially not a new one.
Prefer smaller homes, don’t buy
gas stoves, live closer to where
you work, but also, one of the most
important things anyone can do,
and anyone can actually do this
one, is to be informed on the
different policies and laws that
governments create to try and
solve these problems.
Because we
can’t do this without an
informed public, and policies need
advocates, so they need people
who understand it, so we can have
these conversations in ways that
make sense, and unfortunately it’s
pretty complicated so it isn’t
immediately obvious how any of
this works.
But if you just watch
this video you are going to be more
informed than 99% of the people in
your country on how this stuff works.
This one video.
Now you can go
deeper than that and I encourage you to,
but this is a good place to start.
But before we do that, a couple points
of clarification.
One, I’m going to be
saying carbon a lot.
And when I say
carbon, I mean carbon dioxide which
is the chief heat-trapping gas that
we emit into the atmosphere.
But I don’t just mean carbon dioxide,
I also mean the equivalent amounts
of other gases that also trap heat,
methane being the primary one.
Methane actually traps 84x the heat
of carbon dioxide, we just release
a lot less of it thankfully.
So we have
equivalency measures, so 1 ton of
methane released will be equivalent
to 84 tons of CO2.
This way we
end up talking about all greenhouse
gases in the frame of carbon dioxide
which is why people often just say carbon.
Now second, we’re used to thinking of
global warming as a problem of, like,
our transportation, maybe our homes,
maybe agriculture.
Because those
are the things we have the most direct
contact with.
But this is a big, mixed up
jumble of a problem.
You can pause the
video if you want to get a low down
about where all the carbon is coming
from, this is a very useful chart from
Dr. Anna Ritchie at Our World in Data.
Alright, here we are.
We have actually arrived.
We’re going to talk about what strategies
governments use and can use to
rapidly decrease their emissions
of greenhouse gases.
And there are
big categories of these, there’s carbon
pricing, and then there’s everything else.
Carbon pricing looks at the problem
with a pretty clear vision, if releasing
carbon dioxide is free, people don’t
have any reason not to do it.
But it’s
actually not free, it’s going to cost a
tremendous amount of money to deal
with the consequences of the emission of that
carbon.
But that money isn’t being paid
by the people producing the emissions
or the people consuming the energy,
the gas, the steel, the concrete that
create the emissions, those costs
will be born by people in the future
and they will be wildfires and
droughts and famines and wars and
refugees and sea level rise.
All of those
are costs that are not being priced in.
So carbon pricing just includes those
costs, and there are 3 main ways to do that.
The first is just pricing carbon,
and this actually weirdly has had some
pretty bipartisan support.
People further
on the right or the left don’t like this,
but in the center where market based
solutions feel really good, people like this.
The basic idea is that whenever a
fossil fuel or another source of emissions
enters the economy, whether it’s at the
moment it’s taken out of the ground or
at the moment of entry when we import it,
you tax it.
You say, “this will soon be burned,
and that will produce a ton of carbon
and a ton of carbon is going to cost the
world $50 to deal with in the future,
so we’re going to make this thing
cost $50 extra”.
This is by far the
simplest thing I’m going to talk about
today to actually implement.
It’s easy to regulate, you don’t have
to worry about different industries
lobbying to get better deals, and
everyone pays the same flat rate
and this significantly increases the
cost of fossil fuels, thus encouraging
investment and innovation in other
options.
Now there’s a sub category
of this idea, which is what do you then
do with all of this money?
Any carbon
price that is anywhere near the actual
long term cost of releasing the carbon will
at first generate a lot of cash.
And there are
two basic ideas: the first is to use it to
the work of decarbonizing our economy.
Invest in new research, mass transit, solar
power plants, job training for people
who used to work in the fossil industry.
But the second idea confronts the
biggest problem with the carbon tax,
which is that it is a tax.
Pricing
carbon increases the costs of
heating a home, of commuting to
work, of flying to see your family.
And nobody likes that.
So instead
of giving the money to governments
to invest in decarbonizing the economy,
the current more favored and more
palatable plan, is just to take the money
that we raise and give it to people.
You divide the pot by exactly the
number of people who live in the country,
and you give everyone the exact
same check.
This is called the carbon
fee and dividend.
Now the money that
comes out of this isn’t enough to be
like a universal basic income kind of thing,
but it is enough that it covers the increase
costs of the heating and the driving for
most people.
Not for the wealthiest people,
but mostly for people who are on the lower
end of the income spectrum, their extra
costs will be covered.
But that doesn’t
mean that the system is totally fair, people
in rural areas use a lot more energy than
people in the cities.
But everyone is
going to get the same sized check,
and I think that lack of fairness will
probably cause some
tension.
Just guessing.
Now another problem with the
carbon tax is that it treats everything
the same, which is what a lot of
people like about it, but some
industries are way easier to decarbonize
than others.
And some are far more
hot politically like people care a lot
more about gas prices than they do
about steel prices.
So what if you
could create a plan that found the
cheapest ways to decarbonize and
prioritized them first so you have roughly
the same amount of carbon decreasing
but you give some more time to the
industries where it’s more difficult to
decarbonize.
That sounds like something
that a market would be good at.
And
thus we have, cap and trade.
Again, very basically, there’s a cap
that’s the total amount of emissions
that the government’s going to allow, and
then they distribute or sell permits to
different polluters.
And then those polluters,
if they don’t use up all their permits,
can sell
or trade on an open market
their permits for pollution.
As the caps get lower with time, the
permits become more scarce and
more expensive, thus decarbonizing
becomes more worth it.
This worked
extremely well in decreasing the
amount of sulfur dioxide released
by coal plants in the 1980s.
Sulfur dioxide reacts with water in the
atmosphere to create sulfuric acid,
was making the rain literally acidic,
some pieces of statues washed away
and forests died in droves, and we
solved that problem with a cap and trade
system on sulfur emissions.
This creates a
market that can act like a market and the
people who can most inexpensively decrease
their emissions do it first, and then over
time as the cap gets lower and lower and lower,
everybody has to join.
But cap and trade
of course has it’s issues, certain pollutants
often start out with free polluter credits,
often times they can offset their pollution
super inexpensively with unproven credits,
and it’s very vulnerable to lobbying by
big
emitters.
They can convince legislators that
they need to be carved out, or given more
permits, so that companies can afford
more lobbyists get better deals.
Cap and trade does work, it’s being
used all over the world, it’s just more
complicated than it initially
sounds.
As all of this is.
Hank from the future, I forgot to say
that cap and trade also generates revenue,
so you have the same questions
about whether to spend it on
decarbonization or just distribute it
as a dividend or lower taxes or some
mix of those things.
But both of those
systems we just talked about,
they intentionally increase the price
of carbon, that’s what we’ve been
talking about right?
It’s carbon pricing.
We have to increase the price in order
to incentivize alternatives.
But people
do not like it when their government is like,
“hey your prices are going to go up.”
Especially when they’re going to go up
for everybody and that’s going to
affect some people a lot more than others.
It’s hard, though not impossible to get
people on board with this stuff.
There are carbon taxes and cap and trade
schemes all over the world right now.
But this does lead us to our final and
most futuristic option for pricing carbon.
Instead of charging people for
releasing carbon, you pay them to stop
it from being released or to capture
it again.
Kim Stanley Robinson the
science fiction writer calls this
“carbon quantitative easing” quantitative
easing being the weird economics
term for just dumping lots of money
into an economy.
Basically this just
switches the carbon pricing on its head.
Instead of saying “hey we’re going to
charge you for emitting,” we’re going
to
pay you for not emitting.
And it makes
sense because there are two ways to think
about the costs of emitting carbon, one is
to say this is going to cost a lot of money
if we emit it, the other is to say this is
going to save a lot of money if we prevent
it from being emitted.
So the ideas is,
as long as the US federal reserve is printing
money hand over fist, might as well tie
some positive result to that.
Whoever can
prove that they prevented CO2 from
entering the atmosphere or permanently
stored it from the atmosphere just gets paid.
They could potentially even get
paid with like a global carbon coin, a
currency that every country uses that’s
tied to the value of removal
of CO2 from the air.
There are problems with this.
Of course as well, there’s a large
bureaucracy necessary for counting these
things and preventing fraud.
The fossil
fuel companies would have to be paid,
given lots of money to keep their
carbon locked up and that feels a
little unfair, and then of course there’s
the tremendous cost.
The taxes
generate revenue, this is
the opposite of that.
Now frustratingly,
all carbon pricing strategies are looking
less and less likely in my country
the US right now.
In part, because of
the reason many people like them.
They’re simple economic strategies that
just price the carbon and let the market
figure everything else.
But that also
means that there’s a tremendous
lack of control over what’s actually happening.
And that means that maybe the
costs get pushed off onto marginalized
communities and that the benefits of
these new economic systems,
they’re going to go to the people
who have the access and the money
and the connections to build the
companies that will do all the work.
Now does it matter who gets
rich if we get the carbon out of the
atmosphere, well, this is a thing that
people disagree about, especially the
people on the left.
And at the moment
in my country, it doesn’t matter what
people on the right think because they’re
not going to vote for any of this stuff.
So if you can’t get all the democrats to
vote for a carbon tax, you’re not going
to
get a carbon tax.
Which is why in the
US we are currently planning to do
the other thing, not carbon pricing,
but just everything else.
Passing tons of different laws and
policies and regulations that do
tons of different things.
This is honestly
probably the more progressive way
to do things, to pay more attention
and control things more tightly,
whereas the more conservative thing
to do would be, let’s create a market,
let everything handle itself, get the big
government out of it.
And this
hodgepodge of tons of new ideas,
they fall largely into 3 different groups.
First, we have standards.
Standards
are rules that affect what industries can
do.
So cars have to be more efficient or
they have to be electric, power companies
have to decommission coal plants and
build wind and solar.
Instead of saying,
“hey it’s going to be a lot more expensive
to build fossil fuels in the future,”
they just say “hey, by the year 2050
you can not be burning fossil fuels
anymore.”
The second is investment.
The government looks for early,
mid and late stage opportunities to
help new technologies come to market.
They spend capital on mass transit and
buy electric cars and buses and build
charging infrastructure.
They help people
make their homes more energy efficient.
And the third and final leg of this stool
is
justice.
Help people who are most affected
by decarbonization find fulfilling work,
spend money on the communities
who have been most negatively
impacted by existing polluting infrastructure.
We’re going to be spending a ton
of money to solve this problem,
the people who benefit shouldn’t
just be the ones who created the problem.
You sometimes see this slate of
the climate agenda referred to as
“SIJ” Standards Investment and
Justice.
Now this falls short of a full
Green New Deal type framework
which would add even more on the
justice end with policies like Medicare
for all and a job guarantee.
But it is a
very, very big plan that has not been
finalized much less passed.
President Biden
has said though that he will not sign his
1.2 billion dollar infrastructure package
unless there is also a climate plan
on his desk.
So like, here’s hoping.
Now an important thing here, you
do not have to do just one of these things.
You can have a carbon tax, and a
cap and trade system, and pay people
to remove carbon from the atmosphere,
and have standards investment and
justice regulations.
And these plans
exist all over the place.
China, Canada and
the whole European Union have a cap and
trade system, Japan, Turkey, Thailand, Indonesia
and a bunch of other places have
carbon taxes, and pretty much everywhere
has some amount of broad climate
regulation.
And which of these things am
I most in favor of?
All of them.
I want to
do anything we can get done.
But it is super helpful to understand
the basics of how all of these things work.
Especially because in this whole video
which has not been short or simple, I have
only talked about what individual countries
do.
But of course this can not be done by one
country.
The conversation about how to
create a multi national set of enforceable
standards on carbon pricing or just targets
to achieve generally is an order of magnitude
more complicated even than any of this.
But if you watched this video and you
understood it, you now have joined a
pretty exclusive club.
You are one of the
people who understands the basics of
how governments try and decrease their
greenhouse gas emissions through laws
and regulations.
And that is amazing,
but you can go further.
And I encourage
you to go further.
I’d suggest a podcast
called Pricing Nature to understand the
complexities of carbon pricing and
international agreements.
You should also
check out David Roberts’ newsletter at Volts.wtf
and if you want to get very wonky in a
science fiction framework, try out the Ministry
of the Future by Kim Stanley Robinson.
Also I have to say thank you so much to
the people at Our World In Data who
provide a tremendous service to our entire
world with a pretty tiny team.
Their site and
all their information on climate change is
extremely illuminating to peruse and I
encourage you to go spend time there,
I’ve given them a 1,000 donation as a
thank you because of how much it helped
me make this video.
And also because you
cannot solve the problem
if you don’t understand it.